so my first question for y'all I got to
I got an opportunity to watch y'all and
it's you know it's interesting seeing
the family Dynamic right
um so with having your family filmed
being on camera all the time what do you
love and what do you hate most about it
I I mean we have a really good crew that
we work with so I love getting to see
them and they're you know in our lives a
lot for this period of time that we're
filming I love that and I love whenever
the four of us get to be together to
film I think that's probably my favorite
I love the fact that you get to see what
our lives are really like the good and
the bad and because on social media
which were which we're known for it you
just get this these Snippets of what you
think we're all about and I think the
show depicts a little bit digs a little
bit more d deeper into into who we
really are as people that makes sense
absolutely oh did you have something
else to add I was gonna say you you
wanted the flip side of that I'm trying
to think that's right I think the
hardest part is
um because we did film earlier in the
year so it's like we did so much I kind
of forget so that's probably like but
that's just you know I'm 51 so I just
forget a lot of things but probably the
rehashing of the negative stuff that's
already you know I mean family squabbles
and things are are little piece and if
you look look at our whole family uh as
a piece of pie like 90 of it are
positive and and then you rehash these
little parts we actually have to think
back and go wait what oh did I say that
so it makes sense that makes sense it's
um it's interesting I imagine it's in
watching everything after you've gone
through it like you've just kind of
mentioned
um what is how is it how does it feel
watching your daughters going through
these incredibly vulnerable moments on
camera like as a parent because I'm not
a parent so I I don't know the depth of
that emotion I have an idea of it but
I'm curious to hear from the both of you
I think it's you know people say that
all the time about us and and the the
magnification of having so many people
watching you but I think it's the same
it's the same pain that we used to have
when before all the Limelight happened
you feel as a parent you feel the pain
that's the hardest and sharpest pain for
me when your kids aren't doing well or
they're struggling and and I think with
this whole situation it's been it's been
somewhat Amplified and the positive
things are so positive and the negative
things make national news sometimes so
it's but we learn to deal with it over
the last few years it's been it's been
it's been pretty good
anything from you Hattie do you have
anything to add
I mean he pretty much summed it up in a
nutshell I mean it sometimes it's just
you know
to other people it's like how is it
you know seeing all of this play out on
camera but this is our real life so we
we see it in real time and sometimes
forget it's gonna be on camera and and
out there until until it's out there and
then people who watch the show come up
to the girls or us and just say you know
I you made me feel less alone and that
was that meant a lot to me that you
shared so awesome well I have one more
question
um what is one lesson you want viewers
to take away from this upcoming season I
would say that we're
um a normal family whatever that means
to anyone out there people think because
we because the girls have followers and
they see us in the Limelight we're we
should have we have the same struggles
we had back when we were living in uh in
Connecticut and growing up and and and
life is life is is tough and pause is
wonderful and tough for us as it is for
everyone else and I think if we could
show uh whoever's watching how we
navigate through it and they get
something out of it that's great yeah
any Heidi anything else to add
um I think a takeaway is
um yeah we we're
share our life on social media but as
you see in the show it's very normal and
pretty much every way as far as emotions
and family relationships and Dynamics
and you know just to to know that we're
we're a normal family and kind of an
extraordinary situation and we're making
the best of it but we're still learning
and growing uh as we're kind of taking
on this new life amazing yeah I was
gonna say you know it seems like and
what I'm hearing from you and it's the
truth is that there's no particular
framework of what a family looks like
you know what a family goes through so
it's it's always good for folks to see
the different varieties and so I feel
like that's what you're providing um in
your show
thank you of course of course I think my
time is up
um so I want to say thank you both so
much uh for taking this little time out
to talk to me I really appreciate it of
course nice to meet you nice to meet you
you too